Alana Lenten is another critical race
Hustler said to be not racist is a
discursive form of racist violence so to
be not racist is violent so you've got
these anti-racist activists urging
people to be racist in order to not be
racist it makes no sense if you redefine
words and then deny that you are
redefining the words you effectively end
up gaslighting the world it comes from
that 1940 film where you know the
husband is constantly lowering the
lights and the wife is saying why is it
getting dimmer in here and he's saying
no that's just your head it's all in
your mind and that's what they do to us
all the time so they'll say this is a
largely peaceful protest it's burning
buildings behind the guy but he'll just
say oh it's largely peaceful and they
can deny the observable reality in front
of your eyes and they'll do it and
they'll drive you insane and they'll say
you're too stupid to understand critical
race Theory even though the fundamental
precepts are not that difficult to grasp